(liquid pouring)
- The Old Forge was named Britain's
most remote pub by the
Guinness Book of World Records.
- It's located here in Knoydart,
northern Scotland.
Nearly everyone who
tries to get there dies
in the flames.
- Okay. This isn't
Mordor, but it is tricky.
As we found out, one
does not simply walk to
the Old Forge pub.
Plan one: we take the train.
- Isn't that the train from Harry Potter?
- Oh, it is.
So, we pack our gear, jump on the train.
- Enjoy the breathtaking scenery.
- Arrive at the Old Forge.
- Order a pint.
And...
(sighs)
- No, no, no. It doesn't work.
The train doesn't come to Knoydart.
It ends in Mallaig terminal.
- Hey wait. Who is this guy?
- My name is Jean-Pierre Robinet,
and I'm the remotest
public in mainland Britain.
- Oh, okay.
Plan two: We'll walk.
- Here's the plan.
We pack our gear.
- Fill up our water bottles.
- Pack some snacks.
- Prepare for the Scottish wilderness.
- Enjoy the breathtaking scenery.
- Arrive at the Old Forge.
- Order a pint.
And...
(sighs)
- Well, you could.
But to be honest, I don't think you would.
Because it a 18 miles
hike, and is very boggy.
No tracks. Just cross country
through the highlands,
and you could carry all
your gears all the way up,
but I don't know. It's quite difficult.
It's two days hike.
One night in the (mumbles).
- Okay.
Plan three.
We drive.
We pack up our gear.
- We hire a car.
- Make it a four by
four, and hit the road.
Enjoy the breathtaking scenery.
- Arrive at the Old Forge.
Order a pint.
And...
(sighs)
- It's totally impossible to drive here.
The nearest road is 18 miles from here.
So you need to park in
Mallaig, and jump on a boat.
- Oh!
- Full time I will say
around 130 people live
on the peninsula.
Of course, the tourism is the
main part of our business.
We're really busy between
the first of March
and mid October.
We've got the backpackers
and hikers because we on
one of the two best hike in Scotland here.
Here is totally unspoiled.
Knoydart is clearly the
last British wilderness.
- Okay.
Final plan.
We take the ferry.
- We pack our gear.
Buy a ticket.
- Ge on the ferry.
Enjoy the breathtaking scene of...
My God, there are three
whales right next to the boat.
- Whales, literally.
- Arrive in Knoydart.
Wave good-bye to the ferry Captain.
Arrive at the Old Forge.
Order a pint.
And...
♫ Congratulations
- You made it.
(upbeat music)